hi I'm Evan Carmichael
welcome to the edition of ask Evan
today's question come from one of my
newsletter readers Freddie who was
asking about started a new business and
he wrote insane many entrepreneurs lock
objectivity and real insight into the
market when starting the business in
what ways are these considered pitfalls
in selecting a new venture
please help so thanks for the question
Freddie
very true a lot of entrepreneurs start a
business without really knowing the
market or really having a customer base
and they end up closing down their
company because they're not able to make
enough money to support themselves and
that's really phase one for any
entrepreneur is getting past survival
right you have to be able to make enough
money from your business the Perry bills
put food on the table survive right if
you can't make enough money to survive
then you're not gonna be able to sustain
business for very long so it all starts
with building around your customer base
so a lot of entrepreneurs will start a
business because I think it's a great
money-making opportunity but they're not
really passionate about that business
and they haven't talked to any potential
customers did you think it's a fantastic
money-making idea usually when you're
going after just making money you rarely
end up making money and that's one of
the one of the ironies of running the
business if you look at they're really
successful entrepreneurs they didn't
start their business because they wanted
to make a lot of money that's part of it
you know you're gonna make money but
they wanted to start the business
because they had an intense passion
forth they're doing and they wanted to
help people
so I'd look for you know for whatever
business you're trying to start look at
what you're really good at what you you
have a strong passion for and you feel
like it helped a lot of people that
that's where you want to start and if
your be able to help people you're gonna
make money the more the more value can
provide people the more you can help
them the more money you're gonna be able
to make in your business so money is
definitely part of it you know if you're
not making enough money to survive
you're not gonna stay in business but
the first principle is really being able
to do something that you're really
passionate about and you're able to add
a lot of value and help people with so
that's where I would start next you
could be really passionate or something
but not having intense
you know understanding of what your
customers are going through so before
really starting the business I'll go and
start talking to potential customers get
to know their challenges get to know
their pain points see how you can help
them open up friendly conversations
you're not selling them anything you're
just going to ask for help
ask for some advice and see if you might
be able to provide some assistance it's
great if you can build a business around
a paying customer I would try to talk to
you potential customers again understand
their pain points and try to set up a
relationship where you can get them on
board as a customer before you even
launch whatever product or service that
you're providing that's you know great
because you have cash flow coming in
most entrepreneurs start the other way
they spend a lot of money creating
whatever product or service they launch
it and then hustle and try to get enough
business to support you know all that
money that they spent words better to
try to go the other way around
you know that first model can still work
but it's a lot more expensive and a lot
more risky better ways to go either
around start talking to your customers
first find out about their challenges
and try to build around them and get
your first customer right at the gate so
you have cash flow coming in that you
can use to then pay for all your
marketing expenses pay for whatever
products you need to buy and start
growing your business
so that's what I would do I think a lot
of entrepreneurs again as you mentioned
do it the wrong way to think they have a
great idea but they don't really have a
strong desire to to build that business
I have a passion for it
and they don't really know much about
their customers so again make sure
you're targeting a business around one
of your intense passions we know you can
help a lot of people in a really
meaningful way and then try to build
around your customer by talking to them
find out what their pain points are
hopefully that helps you guys like the
video please give her a thumbs up below
I always love seeing those come in and
it makes me want to do more of these
videos for you guys
and if you have a thought about this
video you want to add your two cents or
if you have a question for me as well
please leave a comment below I'd love to
hear what you're thinking and I'll see
you on the next episode
you